actually until 1974 the National Weather
Service issued tornado alerts and
warnings did not come into play until
the Doppler radar system which was able
to spot rotation family dog is in some
sort of danger cliche chickens are dicks
to people trying to survive tornadoes
yeah you need human intervention during
a tornado if all you put on this storm
shelter was a bathroom stall locking pin
well at least the dog is safe also maybe
the dad didn't know this would happen
but seems to me he would have been
totally okay staying with his family
instead of trying to keep the door
closed once the door blew off nothing
happened to his wife and daughter or
thankfully the dog this is gonna be a
long day cliche dude on his way to pick
up contentious divorce papers brings new
fiance because conflict a sector scan
west-northwest look at mid levels for
rotation and increase the PRF went
through technobabble hard to believe but
this guy is going to be a respected
actor in a couple years
national severe storms laboratory issues
never seen anything like it warnings I
wanted to do a loss joke here but I also
wanted to do a mom sex spanking the
monkey reference here and now I can't
think of anything but a masturbating
smoke monster 1996 Alan hunt isn't my
girlfriend in this scene Joe hardly puts
her high school class ring on our left
ring finger instead of her right for
some reason seriously this has always
bugged me what is she trying to do here
hide the fact that she's still wearing
her wedding ring because a fail bill
spotted that as soon as he arrived and
be can't lick over the past girl can't
lick over the past the suck saw every
single conversation I have ever had with
a woman involving the phrase the suck
zone has ended in a slap in the face a
restraining order or me sleeping on the
couch 1996 cell phone coverage out in
the middle of bumfuck Oklahoma sure I
mean with what we're about to see in
this movie regarding cell phone coverage
this is actually pretty tame but still
simple of them so you've been running
out of grant money and you somehow built
four of these things haha copyright
infringement but you want to be here for
the first time out that's why I didn't
sign the divorce papers
it is great what is it movie
conveniently gives us clueless character
with tons of questions so we can get the
exposition without it being long clunky
enforced measure all parts of the
tornado simultaneously all parts
seriously all the parts
that's incredible if we knew
tornado really worked we could design an
advanced warning system Looby tries to
add importance to its tornado which
caused massive destruction plot by
giving these storm chasers a device that
justifies their dangerous work and we
won't miss out on flying cows if we can
get this new information we can increase
warning time to 15 minutes you just said
no one knows what's going on inside a
tornado and your machine will provide
the first-ever data about the inside of
a tornado and yet you were already able
to calculate the time savings on tornado
warnings from said untested machine I
can't believe you actually did it
yeah amazing considering that it seems
to be a fairly simple device if you have
the know-how and you obviously have way
more money to do it when bill was around
get it in the tornado well you got to
get in further tornado and put it in the
damage path I'm trying to figure out the
best way to say I want to punch bill
paxton in the face every time he says
something but it always comes out to me
we got major action bill comes out to
get the divorce papers signed at the
perfect time for tornado to revive his
marriage haha I don't care when this
movie was made that laptop is ridiculous
here come the evil tornado chasers black
trucks Black Arts went out and got
himself some corporate sponsors
corporate sponsors are bad
brought to you by this dodge I'm driving
the whole movie you said it for the
money not the science yeah but just
because your motives aren't pure doesn't
mean you can slide off and be a tornado
chasing it's like if you're the running
back Chris Johnson right you don't get
that money if you're terrible so come
back okay so he has a CB in his new
truck that was never meant for tornado
chasing why again also if he needed to
flag down Joe about these oh so
important divorce papers why didn't he
use it before yeah what's Jonas doing
here he's a tornado chaser random
asshole van somehow can't get around
billing his truck for no reason other
than random-ass wholeness also the van
is behind the truck here now all the
sudden it's on the side and there's a
drunk driver and it's swerving into bill
who amazingly reacted to the van before
it even started to swerve awesome
tornado chaser can't change a simple
flat tire decides to spend money on an
auto mechanic to do the job illness just
happens to be getting interviewed about
the tornado predicting system he stole
right across the street from where Bill
is getting his tire change this is like
when Pixar and DreamWorks found out
about each other's competing talking ant
movies this is like whenever Facebook
learns of a new website or app with a
word face or book in the name Dorothy
Tucker damn think bill paxton tries to
set the record for the most ridiculous
line readings at a pre Nicolas Cage in
Wigram an era a satellite calmly god I'm
bored pulse-doppler we got next red
real-time weather dragon pissing contest
yes the dirt will tell me where that
tornado will land
why create Dorothy when you just have
natural dirt reading skills going great
great like the screen you're standing in
front of even today in 2014 you would
have trouble getting a signal out in the
middle of Oklahoma with half the major
cell carriers and that's without driving
into a massive storm system yeah
anything named after boobs is okay with
me
no Joe was entirely too cool considering
they're about to run into a tractor on
the side of the road also large obstacle
out of nowhere is avoided at the last
second cliche characters don't realize
everyone can hear them never seen that
before sure you can read that these
tracks are fresh from your van I wasn't
gonna say anything about the jeep
product placement here because I already
rag on the Dodge Chrysler but as soon as
this Jeep logo leaves the center frame
what replaces it an oncoming Jeep
Cherokee tornado does not contain sharks
do you know that you guys just radio
that you lost visual with that awesome
even if it is Oklahoma PAH can't totally
died right there probably for no reason
see no need to give details you'll see
it man don't worry just a tornado what's
the worst that could happen with 30
yards of standing water this truck
definitely hits the bridge with too much
velocity isn't that the point aren't you
supposed to get in the damaged path to
drop your Dorothy if bill doesn't make
the wrong call here this movie's a brisk
35 minutes and everyone's happy I will
blame this bridge for being super
convenient but we all know that
overpasses are horrible places to be for
tornadoes and these tornado experts
should know that where's my truck course
tornadoes have excellent comic timing is
it possible for her to have driven
around this yellow truck and still ended
up in this position very pretty truck
don't even think about it
no way well she must have presented a
very compelling case because bill had no
idea that all those black vehicles he
was passing were part of this dude's
entourage where is Bill's team right now
it's gonna shift this track bill could
simply teach a course on how to find and
follow tornadoes and there would be no
need for any Dorothy ever even though
Bill's been stopped for at least 10
seconds and he lost Jonas's convoy there
are still evil black vans that need to
pass him lucky his held dirt road takes
them to the exact spot they need to get
into the path of the tornado when it
changes its course luckiest all dirt
road turns into a normal highway out of
nowhere looks like there's an Anderson
movie accidentally puts its narrator
into one of the black vans my fiance
should probably not be in the back of
this truck now either why did they take
her on a tornado chase again you know
why this truck didn't get destroyed and
our heroes didn't get killed after
getting hit by two tornadoes at once
because Dodge Ram that's why this is the
second time this movie has found that
gag funny if you want to have Melissa
act we were one of the tracing tornadoes
that makes sense but here you're making
it seem like she's never had a
home-cooked meal in her life ah here's
one of Hollywood staples two characters
destined to be together
awkwardly have to dance around each
other's personal space look I could
point out that bill came out with two
buttons undone and now in here there are
three but that would be extremely
nitpicky what I really want to say is
button your shirt asshole you're at the
dinner table well relocate your house
fairly efficient
is there an f5 where did everyone think
the logical conclusion of this
conversation was headed you're sitting
here casually talking about tornado
strength and you get up to f4 and you
didn't think f5 was gonna come up I just
want you to know that this song in this
movie officially ended van Halen not
saying that's a good or bad thing I'm
just saying that's what happened
coincidental timing is coincidental
you nearly ran into those guys after
taking a corn field shortcut and you can
still be a dick about it
just because you're one of the good guys
not to mention the wanton destruction of
delicious corn you fuckers to get off
this road first off Joe you should know
that this asshole never guesses he's
always right second off this guy is
always right
just turn miracle dirt roads are
everywhere in Oklahoma it's like if the
game portal was dirt roads yeah it's not
like you haven't done that the whole
movie and also when it's Bill upper
right this tornado height is better than
1998 Godzilla hey so if she's gonna use
that to talk to the team why did we need
that sexy bill has to wire her up scene
a few moments ago I see that the utility
poles from the movie volcano went to
this movie school of inconveniencing the
protagonist first how do you not know
you've predicted everything else
technically you haven't either you were
busy saving your dog and looking into
the skylight when your dad was trying to
hold the cellar door down Joe and Bill
are arguing and are apparently
completely safe despite having just
driven 100 yards backwards from the
sudden tornado which is apparently gone
I guess I don't know you can man this
would be really leans heavily on the
people over here something on the radio
or hot mic gimmick and wouldn't you have
to be pressing down on the talk button
this entire conversation take a look at
this you better take a look at this
cliche we way better movie begins
showing but does not end twister oh it's
a double feature of the shining and
psycho yeah that's gotta be one of the
most dialogue free double features ever
the screen only shows iconic images from
The Shining pen stealing
heartfelt moment where bill basically
told Joey still loves her and Brooke
Melissa's heart leads Joe to sign the
divorce papers even though we saw a
scene with her stupid end verifying she
also still loves Bill
it's coming I realized tornadoes can
form really fast but since Dusty's
watching the weather gear this sudden
surprising drive-in tornado should not
be nearly this surprising even if it
fallen quickly this tornado also
wouldn't form so fast is to be
undetectable but then also be a half
mile wide monster at the same time are
these concession workers still doing
inside the concession stand the screen
was pretty much toast a minute ago but
it respectfully waits until the
Shining's here's Johnny part comes up
because tornados and movie screens
always work together to create a sense
of irony bunch of tornado experts decide
to seek shelter in an auto mechanic shop
full of sharp and heavy tools follow
instructions ok tornados have been
consistently hitting Oklahoma all day my
weather equipment is going haywire back
to reading Dante's Inferno I guess which
double sucks because Joe's aunt lives
there I shake my hand in the air and
yellow damn you tornadoes now it's
personal another mad for any of the
staff
well I'm glad they got that love
triangle resolved so easily I wonder why
it was something I worried about so much
no one has crossed off one of the fives
on this sign yet I know it's almost like
a tornado came through here no gravitas
hey those tornado victims look just like
the ones in our opening flashback movie
tries to make us think the main
characters are actually in danger after
an entire film of scenes have proven
them to be utterly unkillable see even
aunt Megan or dog are unkillable or
pilot keeper over not just to be safe
just pour some tickle into my mouth and
feed me some nails I've got a house to
rebuild tomorrow ah once again I am so
thankful the dog is okay Oh cue movie
also phew just in time can you imagine
what would have happened if bill broke
up with Melissa longer because tornadoes
like screenwriters need to up the ante
it's okay we've established that Aunt
Maggie is very tough can we get to the
last tornado already it's gotta stop now
you're just beating a dead dad also how
much warning do you need how many miles
of Oklahoma is this movie covering there
have been tornadoes all day the NSSL is
already established that a
record-breaking amount of tornadoes in
Oklahoma is possible and several have
touchdown already and then all your own
weather equipment was going crazy out in
the yard I don't see how you didn't have
any warning Joe happen to somebody else
you go stop go stop it you go stop it
the point of this is to create a warning
system not stop the tornadoes what a
tornado is something that need to get
captured in a genie bottle Joe sees this
artwork in aunt Meg's yard and has a
convenient epiphany to put little pin
wheels on all the sensors which is a
long way of me saying sculpture ex
machina nothing from the coca-cola
company though because that would just
be wrong why is that the sunniest day
ever a few hundred feet from an f5
tornado can I as an on weather science
guy ask a question why isn't this a
success the sensors are scattered all
over and the tornado will surely pick up
most or all of them why did the sensors
have to be sucked up into the tornado
but can only do so via the dorothea
system which appears to be a light metal
can man perfect game every time this
random act of nature really knows how to
put movie protagonists right in harm's
way
petroleum truck getting thrown at a
speed close to 300 miles an hour only
nudges Bill's truck and even lends a
helping hand by dislodging it from the
tree I'm sorry
near dead
you are in that fire for seven seconds I
mean maybe the trick is not minding but
the rest of this movie is probably just
a dream by the angels of your charred
corpses in a kiss to life isn't this
something that you would have figured
out we the back in the drawing room on
these things sand this tornado has
better aim than any bad guy in any
action movie ever ha ha he's dead now
but considering the tone of the rest of
this movie that I just watched that's
pretty dark you have a cure for getting
exploded does she think she's helping
sorry Joan that's at least the second
time you should have died in this movie
trekker totally smashes the windshield
but then at the very next cut no worries
you imagined it all this line reading
it's like a theme park ride where all
the scary parts know exactly where the
road is this is where the movie jump the
house I mean shark NATO jump the shark
NATO oh this is stupid and deserves us
in also this is impossible how could
they have entered the house on the
houses first floor gone up or down the
stairs and then exited still on the
first floor also the red Dodge truck is
very thankful that it was a prop house
and not a real one tornado chasers are
dicks to corn again I don't think you
can outrun a tornado much less an f5
with 300 mile per hour winds but yeah
hurry why are you still standing there
Ron I for one thought you guys were
goners yeah it shouldn't surprise you
that Spielberg's the producer on this
movie he also tried to sell that
refrigerators will save you during a
nuclear blast light ooh
also the movie itself knows why this
shouldn't work not only are they likely
pulled out of the ground by a tornado of
this magnitude but even if it worked
maybe human-sized Twizzlers magic
tornado completely dissipates instantly
after our hero survived its carnage
oh good the tornado spared her dad so we
won't have to see twister to bill cops a
feel yeah that tornado sure was generous
horrible couple realizes they can only
love each other while being in tornadoes
I guess Joe and Bill have homey beacons
on or something I mean with a mile wide
f5 tornado I have no other explanation
for how they could possibly have arrived
at this exact spot thirty seconds after
the twister hit
and no one ever died from a tornado
again wait this song
sorry
interrupt Matt please use the phone just
for a second for what I just want to
call Regina on the boat cuz I figure
since we're waiting maybe I could just
you know wow it is great what is it
Donnie you're out of your element
they're like a child who wanders in in
the middle of a movie to the death no to
the pain to the pain means the first
thing you lose will be your feet below
the ankles then your hands at the wrists
don't worry I know Cole he always goes
to the outside belljo it's it's over
little thing with stable and then it's
it's gone right sorry
died but it was a long time ago gotta
move on we're going to survive today we
celebrate our Independence Day
which happens TAS lead no need to be a
pursuit better
that's fine
stupid
we tried there's nothing we could do